تحول مفاجئ للصراع عدوى وحمى الحروب تنتقل
الى السودان الاشتباكات على اشدها
والمواطنون يعيشون وضعا حرجا فما الذي
يجري هديه عظيمه ومهمه من الدنمارك
لاوكرانيا قد تحسم المعارك على الارض
واربعمائه
اوكرانيا في عداد القتلى خلال 24 ساعه
وكيف تكشف عن وجود اسلحه صينيه في المعارك
الاوكرانيه فيما فنلندا تبني جدارا عازلا
امام روسيا فهل يكفي الجدار لصد اسلحه
الروس بوتين يحضر قاطره نوويه لمشروع
فضائي فما الذي ينوي فعله البرازيل والصين
تكتبان نهايه الاقتصاد الامريكي وتركيا
تحصل على مكافاه انضمام فنلندا وبعد تحديه
لكوريا الشماليه رئيس الوزراء الياباني
ينجو من الموت المحقق
روسيا تضع يدها في الحناجر الامريكيه
الروس يهجمون برا وبحرا وجوا والاوكرانيون
ينتظرون رافه الغرب بقليل من السلاح وبعض
من الذخيره فهل ياتي المدد نعم هنا يصل
الدعم الغربي والبسمه تعود للملامح
الاوكرانيه حيث تحدثت الدنمارك عن هديه
عظيمه ومهمه الى اوكرانيا وذلك باعلان
وزاره الدفاع الدنماركيه ان الدبابات
الدنماركيه المانيه الصنع ستكون جاهزه
للشحن الى اوكرانيا وهذا جزء من اتفاقيه
المانيه دنماركيه هولنديه بشان تسليم ما
لا يقل عن 100 دبابه من طراز
الى القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه وفق وكاله
تازه فانت تغني الدبابات الاوكران او
تسملهم من جوع لا يبدو ذلك روسيا لم تعد
لوحدها حيث قال مستشار في الرئيس
الاوكراني ان القوات الاوكرانيه عثرت على
عدد متزايد من المكونات الالكترونيه
الصينيه في الاسلحه الروسيه المستخدمه في
اوكرانيا بحسب وكاله روترز فالحن الوقت
لتكشف بكين عن نفسها كاول دوله في العالم
تقف عسكريا الى جانب روسيا انه لامر صعب
ومعقد للغايه لكن لا شيء يصعب على اصحاب
العيون الضيقه ومع ذلك فعداد القتل في
اوكرانيا يجري بسرعه كبيره حيث افادت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه بتدمير ثلاث مسيرات
اوكرانيه في جمهوريتي
وتصفيه اكثر من 460 جنديا اوكرانيا في
كافه المحاور حسب تصريحهم ليخرج يا وزير
الخارجيه الاوكراني ديميتروكوريبا ويقول
انك مصره على خروج اخر جندي روسي واستعاده
كل الاراضي واكد ان مع الولايات المتحده
مبنيه على الثقه مضيفا انهم يسعون لتحويل
مشكله تسريب الوثائق الى فرصه لتسريع
الحصول على الاسلحه المطلوبه وشاركوا الى
ان اي خطه سلام تتضمن تنازل بلاده عن
اراضي لها هي امر خاطئ سياسيا وقانونيا
واخلاقيا حد التعبيره وبخصوص الوثائق
المسربه فقد صرح وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
بانها
لم يؤثر على علاقات واشنطن بشركائها لكن
تسريب الوثائقي لا يزال طازجا يا هذا
بلتهدئ من روعك قليلا لتظهر بقيه
المعلومات ولتنظر حينها
التسريبات عندها ام لا ومن حرب المعلومات
الى فضائل بوتين النووي حيث وافق الرئيس
الروسي على تطوير مشروع درب التبانه
الفيدرالي والذي من ش تتبع النفايات
الفضائيه في مدار الارض وفق ما اوردته
وسائل اعلام روسيه حتى ان مدير عام مؤسسه
روسكس موس الفضائيه الدوليه لم يستبعد
استخدام قاطرات فضائيه نوويه لتنظيف مدار
الارض من النفايات ضمنا عن اي فضاء نووي
يتحدث هؤلاء ما الذي يخطط له بوتين
سنجيبكم نحن روسيا لا تهرول عبثا من اجل
نظافه الفضاء بل هي تبحث في نفايات امريكا
ودول اوروبا الفضائيه عن بقايا حطام كي
يتم تحليلها ودراستها واكتشاف استراتيجيه
صنعها وكما يقولها العرب اليمنيون من صلي
الا وطالب مغفره وبسبب التحركات الروسيه
والتي لم تكن مريحه للفنديين فنلندا
تبنيسيه على حدودها مع روسيا بعد انضمامها
الى النيتو خوفا من ازمه هجره قد تبتعلها
روسيا انهم
فهل تكفي هذه السياجات لمنع تدفق جيش
بوتين المظلم ومن فنلندا الى قلب العاصمه
الروسيه موسكو حيث وقع الرئيس بلاديمير
بوتين مشروع قانون بشان وضع اجراءات
للاستدعاء الالكتروني بهدف زياده كفاءه
التعبئه العسكريه وسد الثغرات
الروسيه بالعقوبات وفرض عقوبات لمده عشر
سنوات ضد الشركات الروسيه في مجال
التقنيات الرقميه شملت
بكين تضرب اقتصاد امريكا في مقتل
التهديدات لا تكفي والتصريحات لا تفيد
ولابد من خطوات عمليه لتنتصر الصين في
حربها البارده مع امريكا فلربما تاتي
الايام بحرب حقيقيه على الارض نعم يا ساده
التنين الصيني على الصحيحه وهو الرئيس
الصيني شيجن بينج يستقبل نظيره البرازيلي
لولادا سيلفا ليوقع الجانبان عددا من
الاتفاقيات الاقتصاديه والتجاريه المهمه
باعتبار الصين اكبر شريك تجاري للبرازيل
منحيه امريكا جانبا ليس ذلك فحسب بل ان
الصين والبرازيل اتفقت على خطه موت
للدولار الامريكي بعد اعلان التعامل
التجاري بالعملات المحليه فيما بينهما
وبعد سنوات مما تراه بعض الدول اساءه
لاستخدام وضع الدولار الامريكي كعمله
احتياطك اتحدت العديد من اكبر الدول
اقتصاديا واكثرها اكتظاظا بالسكان لاطلاق
بديل للدولار الامريكي واستخدامه في
التجاره العالميه وهذا ما تناقشه منظمه
بريكس بشكل ملح منذ بدء الحرب في اوكرانيا
وكشفت الارقام الاخيره عن تفوق مجموعه
بريكس لاول مره على دول مجموعه الس الاكثر
تقدما في العالم وذلك بعد ان بلغت مساهمه
بريكس
31.5% في الاقتصاد العالمي مقابل
30.7% للقوه السبع الصناعيه حيث تضمر
البرازيل وروسيا والهند والصين وجنوب
افريقيا واضف عليها السعوديه وتركيا
والجزائر تحت مناقشه الانضمام بينما
مجموعه السبع فرنسا والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والمملكه المتحده والمانيا
واليابان وايطاليا وكندا والاتحاد
الاوروبي فهل تكتب نهايه مجموعه السبع الى
الابد
السودان يشتعل
من لا يتعظ بمصير غيره يحصل على نتائج
كارثيه وهو السودان يعيش وضعا صعبا بل
لنقل حربا قد تكون داميه جدا وبعد عامين
من خلافات سياسيه بين قوات الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع انتشرت قوات الدعم
السريع في مروي الشمالي السودان ثم
الخرطوم وعدد من المدن ليمهنهم الجيش وقتا
قصيرا للانسحاب لكن دون جدوى تحدثت
الكارثه حيث اندلعت المواجهه بين القوات
التي يقودها الفريق اول عبد الفتاح
البرهان وقوات الدعم السريع شبه العسكري
المواليه لحليفه سابق محمد حمدانو في تحول
مفاجئ للصراع بينهما الى نزاع مسلح في
الخرطوم وفي عدد من المدن فهذا يعلن
السيطره على المطار وعدد من المناطق
الحيويه للدوله وذاك ينفي او يعلن
استعادتها وبين هذا وذاك دخل مطار الخرطوم
ومطار دائره الاشتباكات وتم احراق بعض
الطائرات المدنيه ليسقط عدد كبير جدا من
الضحايا والمصابين من المدنيين لم يتم
حصرهم بعد وفق لجنه اطباء السودان
المركزيه وهنا قالت قوات الدعم السريعه في
السودان ان عناصر من الجيش السوداني انضمت
الى قوتها بقياده المفتش العام وعدد من
الضباط ليرد الجيش باصدار قرار يقضي بحل
قوات الدعم السريع وانهاء انتداب جميع
ضباط وافراد الجيش لديها على خلفيه
الاحداث الجاريه في البلاد فماذا بعد هذا
اليوم الدامي ايها السودانيون عليكم
بالحوار قبل ان يقع الفاس بالراس وسالوا
اشقائكم العرب ماذا جنو من الحروب
الداخليه
الاحداث والتطورات اعلن المتحدث باسم
الرئاسه التركيه ابراهيم جالين تسريع
انقره لصفقه شراء مقاتله اف 16 الامريكيه
عقب فنلندا الى حلف النيتو وسط مشاهدها
لعين ودور في المكان بعد سماع دوي انفجار
تلاه تصاعد للدخان نجاه رئيس الوزراء
الياباني من محاوله اغتيال خلال كلمته
بحملته الانتخابيه فهل هي رساله من تيم
جونغ يا ترى السودان يدخل منعطفا خطيرا قد
يؤدي بي الى الهلاك برايكم هل يعود
السودانيون عن حربهم هذه قبل ان يقع الفاس
على الراس
[موسيقى]